So this comes to the end, we've got the developer resources and support, as I've
said before, Unreal documentation, always a good resource, Unreal Engine YouTube
channel, I've just kind of like name-chopped some kind of useful
streams there, Unreal Developer Network for licensees, that's for anyone
who's like an actual Unreal Engine licensees, you can get hands-on support
from Unreal Engine developers. For those of us who aren't Unreal Engine
licensees, we have the answer hub, Epic recently announced a new category of
posts that is going to be getting where we're high-traffic answered common problems
that come up on the the UDN, some of those are going to get filtered down
into Unreal answer hub so that you know the the broader community can really
gain the advantages of like what actual you know Unreal Engine licensee
full-time devs are going to have the problems that they're tackling, and last of
all we have the Unreal Engine community which is you know a whole
host of tutorials and presentations by Unreal Community members, the only thing
to mention is again this sometimes this content is a little bit out of date
it's not always the most efficient solutions to these problems but still a
very very rich and powerful resource. So that is it, that is the end of our
last of our five presentations, thank you so much for watching, if you've been
here for the whole five it's been a wonderful journey, I hope I haven't
melted brains too much, and have fun being a programmer in Unreal
Engine, good luck, goodbye.